the cast of Frasier is what made it one
of the greatest sitcoms of all time
sadly some of the people who provided
the laughs are no longer with us
while Renee oberjonwa enjoyed a long and
successful career as a character actor
starting in the mid-60s he's best
remembered as the shape-shifting alien
security Chief Odo on Star Trek Deep
Space Nine a couple of years after DS9
ended oberge Noir made two appearances
on Frasier as the lead characters
Harvard Mentor Dr William Tewksbury
Tewksbury is introduced in season 8's
Frasier's Edge when Frasier is honored
with a Lifetime Achievement Award Dr
Tewksbury sends Fraser a congratulatory
bouquet of flowers with an innocent note
that Frasier takes for an insult
triggering him to confront his old
Professor later that season in the
Wizard and Roz Frazier is shocked when
his producer Roz begins dating
Tewkesbury oberjinwan never stopped
working and along with his spot on
Frasier he played many more memorable
roles before his passing the actor died
of metastatic lung cancer in 2019 he was
79 years old
one of the foundations of Marty's
character is his time with the Seattle
PD throughout the series we get to see
him with his old friends from the force
and that's where the late Bill Gratton
comes in Gratton plays one of Marty's
more vocal old buddies Leo he first
shows up in season 2's Dukes we hardly
knew ye hanging with Marty and Company
in their favorite bar
he's part of the Entourage later that
season and retirement is murder
congratulating Marty on solving a cold
case from before his retirement his
final Frasier appearance is in season
5's where every bloke knows your name
playing cards and seriously bumming raws
out about the prospect of her daughter
growing up while Gratton was never a
leading man in Hollywood he scored
numerous one-offs and recurring roles
over the years in popular shows like
cheers ER and the practice one of his
most visible roles was as Earl the
plumber in The Green Mile where he
famously complains about having to wear
a tie in prison before watching a
performance by an inmate's pet mouse
tragically gretton passed away in 2011
after a long illness at the age of 71.
John lamada only had a couple of
appearances on Frasier but he was a
fairly important figure in Marty Crane's
life lamada plays Duke the owner and
bartender of the establishment named
after him as for the owner himself we
first find Duke tending the bar in
season two's Dukes we hardly knew ye
when Niles's order of Sherry doesn't
impress Duke very much regardless of
whose son Niles is he shows up again in
season 5's where every bloke knows your
name playing cards with Marty and his
other friends along with playing
Sergeant Ronaldo in the 1985 martial
arts action flick American Ninja
lamada's most visible role was on the
hit sitcom elf lamada passed away in Los
Angeles in 2014 at the age of 75.
in Fraser's seventh season the three
faces of Frasier Grant stuck to Crane a
distinct honor at one of Seattle's most
prestigious restaurants Frazier is given
his own portrait unfortunately the
recreation of Frasier includes a
humongous forehead something the
psychiatrist has a difficult time
letting go of the owner of the
restaurant who unveils the offending
caricature is one of the most celebrated
actors to ever appear on Frasier Stefano
is played by the late oscar-nominated
actor Robert Loggia son of a gun get out
of here
logia enjoyed a long career as a
character actor beginning in 1951 and
earned a long list of impressive credits
during his time in Hollywood he earned a
reputation for playing rough bad guys
and some of the roles he's most known
for were members of organized crime like
Frank Lopez in the classic crime drama
Scarface and the rebellious feature in
season 5 of The Sopranos on the other
side of the spectrum he's remembered
fondly as the toy company owner McMillan
in the comedy film big after battling
Alzheimer's for five years logia died in
2015 at the age of 85. Together Jack
Saito and rosemary Murphy appear twice
on Frasier as the Larkins the married
couple Niles is initially desperate to
impress when he gets a new apartment in
season fours to kill a talking bird
unfortunately Niles is newly acquired
white bird that refuses to leave his
head puts a damper on their get-together
in spite of Frasier's best efforts to
cover for his brother the pair appear
again season 6's TAPS at the Montana
where Niles's failure to impress his
neighbors inspires the condo board to
rescind his leaves Murphy may very well
have been cast in To Kill a talking bird
as a nod to her most well-known role in
1962 she appeared as Marty Atkinson in
the acclaimed film adaptation To Kill a
Mockingbird Murphy worked steadily from
the late 40s until 2010 when she made
her final on-screen appearance in the
rom-com The Romantics she was 89 when
she passed from cancer in 2014. while
saito's list of movie and TV credits are
few and far between he was a celebrated
stage actor and director on and off
Broadway Saito passed away in 2010 at
the age of 88. I've got needle and
thread you don't want to lose it do you
I'm trying not to in season six of
Frasier the late Alice Clayton plays the
role of Marty's new love interest Bonnie
Frazier tries to set his father up with
Roz's mother Joanna but Marty has his
eye on Bonnie instead however he breaks
things off in the two-part season finale
shut out in Seattle after Bonnie's dog
has a rendezvous with Marty's dog Eddie
in the park which Marty finds
humiliating known for her High somewhat
childlike voice Clayton was a prolific
voice actor in both incarnations of the
90s animated series Doug for example she
played multiple roles most memorably the
purple-skinned redhead BB Bluff she had
roles in movies like the rom-com IQ and
as the evil Goblin Blitz in the 1985
fantasy film Legend platon passed away
in 2011 at the age of 63 after a
lifetime of dealing with juvenile
diabetes and complications from
pancreatic cancer
one common sitcom Trope that often finds
a home on Frazier is one where the main
character finds what seems like the
ideal romantic partner except for one
unavoidable flaw for example in one of
Fraser's cringier moments the titular
shrink is on cloud nine with his new
girlfriend Mia in the season 7 premiere
Mamma Mia until he realizes she's the
spitting image of his late mother
likewise in season 10's trophy
girlfriend things are going well with
Frasier's new partner Chelsea but their
romance takes a bizarre turn when
Chelsea's job as a gym teacher inspires
painful flashbacks for Frasier of the
abusive cigar chomping coach Fuller
played by the late Bob Hoskins to
American audiences Hoskins is likely
most remembered as private eye Eddie
Valiant from 1988's Who Framed Roger
Rabbit or as Mario in the Super Mario
Brothers live action film adaptation but
across the pond Hoskins was a regular
critically acclaimed feature on the big
screen and the small one appearing in
BBC series and British films like the
1980 gangster drama The Long Good Friday
Hoskins died in April 2014 after out
with pneumonia he was 71 years old
kacl is the professional home to many
eccentric characters and unusual
programs in Frasier among the station's
Talent is a woman often mentioned but
rarely seen 2D the story lady comes up a
lot in Fraser but we don't meet her
until halfway through the series when
the station changes formats throwing all
of its on-air Talent into crisis duty is
portrayed by the late Marcia Kramer most
of Kramer's TV credits were for small
recurring roles or one-offs in series
like new heart cheers and Touched by an
Angel she was also a theater actress who
shared the stage with Sandy Duncan
during the 1979 Broadway production of
Peter Pan her last on-screen performance
proved to be one of her most visible on
the hit sitcom Modern Family Kramer
played the recurring role of Jay's
assistant Margaret Kramer passed away at
the age of 74 in January 2020 Modern
Family director Jeff Greenberg tweeted a
sweet tribute to Kramer writing she was
so delightful in the 14 episodes she
shot as Margaret on Modern Family over
the last seven years but I'll always
remember her soaring Aloft as Wendy to
Sandy Duncan's Peter Pan
this world will be a happier place and
everybody had remember two little words
people stink on the surface the late
John Mahoney's Marty crane has little in
common with his sons he doesn't have
their long lists of degrees he couldn't
care less about the Seattle Elite that
Frazier and Niles are always bending
over backward to impress and he's a lot
less careful about what he says or how
he says it but Frasier wouldn't have
been the same without him as different
as he may be from his sons his love for
them is clear and their back and forth
is priceless Mahoney began his acting
career later in life not studying the
art until he was 37 while he made the
choice later it was a good choice
regardless he would go on to make big
splashes not only in Frasier but in
memorable films like the rom-com
Moonstruck the Coen Brothers film Barton
Fink and the 1996 legal thriller Primal
Fear Mahoney passed away in February
2018 of multiple Health complications
including lung cancer and brain disease
he was 77 his passing was accompanied by
many touching online tributes not only
from Frasier co-stars and crew but other
famous actors whose love and respect
Tony had earned over the years perhaps
the simplest and most heartbreaking
words came from Kelsey Grammer who
tweeted a picture of him hugging Mahoney
along with the words he was my father I
loved him
there were a lot more stars appearing on
Frasier than you may realize of course
some of the biggest names on the series
weren't there in person but instead they
showed up as the troubled callers on
Frasier's radio show sadly there are a
number of these Incognito guests who are
no longer with us one example comes very
early in the series in the second
episode space Quest Frasier receives a
call from a man named Leonard who's
afraid to leave his home the undiagnosed
agoraphobe is voiced by the late
Christopher Reeve who's remembered
fondly for his film role as Superman in
four movies later in the season it isn't
an actor but the late counterculture
psychologist and writer Timothy Leary
who's the first voice you hear in the
show where Lilith comes back Leary
played Hank a caller concerned with his
overeating the late sitcom star Mary
Tyler Moore plays a caller named
Marjorie in the first season's
penultimate episode Frasier Crane's day
off she has the bad luck of calling when
a sick over medicated Frasier has taken
his show back too early from his brother
Niles marjorie's conversation about her
issues with her boss is cut off when
security comes to take Fraser away
who could forget Marty's best friend
Eddie when Marty moves in the adorable
Jack Russell Terrier is perhaps the only
thing Frazier likes less than his
father's recliner and Eddie responds to
his new living arrangements by giving
him long hard stairs Eddie provided
plenty of laughs on the show and for
most of the series he was played by a
dog named moose Kelsey Grammer even
jokingly credited the dog for the series
success while accepting his 1994 Emmy
Award for best actor in a comedy saying
most important moose this is for you
part of Moose's charm was a mischievous
nature and according to his trainer
that's exactly what got him in Showbiz
in the first place reportedly moose was
driving his original owners even more
nuts than moose ever did to Frazier he
was given to birds and animals unlimited
a company specializing in training
animals for entertainment and eventually
to the trainer sadly moose crossed the
Rainbow Bridge at the age of 16. we hope
there was an old recliner waiting for
him and maybe a warm lap
foreign
[Music]